Oh pens no radio newspapers a political
conversation
visitors are once per month I could get
used to this you are the white Mandela
you know the most deluded of them all
we've heard about you too only us for me
tough man we don't plan on staying that
long it's 20 foot high the poor voice
offers everything and should be off
fours with guns locked up into thorn
panels in any direction they just lead
you back on the prison property yeah
everybody comes in here and I'm gonna
break out of here by next week always
the first time that's my thoughts
exactly you want to link it with
accident
no doctor crazy so all we have to do is
make a really complete escape then get
it to reach a keyhole on the other side
of a steel panel three inch thick iron
thought to which we have totally no
access I love it
you fail at 25 years if you're lucky a
bullet in their head of you not
[Music]
what is this No
[Music]
your whole plan is doomed to failure
you didn't do anything
we are prisoners of conscience it's
different for us
well we're prisoners of war
[Music]
where is how much a tipper it's to prank
us this is how we find
hold on today they know that imagine is
another world that's a bonus
[Applause]
[Music]
you